Well, the answer is that given this information, it's completely impossible to say.
Even though I explicitly said that astronaut 1 was at rest and astronaut 2 was moving
was moving towards astronaut 1,
but that situation could equally well be described as astronaut 1 going towards astronaut 2
with astronaut 2 at rest, so what can we say about the motion of astronauts 1 and 2.
Well, one thing we can definitely say that both of these space explorers will agree on
is that the astronauts are definitely getting closer,
but this is interesting that this argument can even show you at all.
Astronaut 1 thought that he was motionless.
Astronaut 2 thought she was motionless.
Yet, clearly, there is some relative motion between them.
This points to something funny going on between motion at a constant speed
and this idea of being at rest.
Why don't we go back to earth to probe this question a little more deeply?